Like we did before, we're going to start off by identifying the constant factors
in this term, and then moving them to the front of the term. So our constant
factors here are negative 5, negative 2, and 3. So we can write negative 5 times
negative 2 times 3, as the first three factors of our rewritten version of this
term. Then after that come the variables, s, r and t. So you multiply the
constant factors by the variable factors. Remember that these multiplication
signs between the variables actually aren't necessary. So I'm just going to get
rid of those right away. Now, negative 5 times negative 2 is just positive 10.
Remember, a negative times a negative. Equals a positive. So then we have 10
times 3, and 10 times 3 is just equal to 30. So we can replace negative 5 times
negative 2 times 3 with 30, and then multiply that with the rest of the factors
that are left over, srt. So our final simplified version of this term is 30 srt.
Now to my eye, this looks much easier to deal with than this initial version of
the term did. So I think we are making really good progress toward simplifying
different expressions.